so wir kommen zum tragen motto ihr habt
sicher noch nie davon gehört
das sind rote fragen und grüne fragen
und die roten sind gemein und die grünen
sind haben wir können selber wählen gut
wie viel und ob und überhaupt dem alle
und ich vermittelten anfang ich finde
einfach die roten selber die besten weil
das gemeinsam und ist immer cool aber
wenn mit ihnen zusammen kommt du musst
das mikro zweierteams mit der stimmen es
steht euch noch bevor habt ihr keine
angst ist wieder durch eure fans
verliert aber soll ich sagen weil damit
jetzt weitere stimmen mit dem vor zwei
jahren vergleicht da sieht man auf jeden
fall unterschied
ich habe mir den hört man ich habe jetzt
keine angst deswegen die fans durch den
stimmbruch verlieren also des täglich
laufen laufenden gange und ist im gange
noch ja dies stimmen länder viel das
weiß ich doch gehen wird aber auf jeden
fall gibt es auf jeden fall schon ein
unterschied wenn man sich im video damit
wenn man sich eines unserer ersten
videos anschaut und jetzt mit unseren
aktuellen vergleich und die stimmen dann
vergleicht dann sieht man auf jeden fall
einen krassen unterschied also finde ich
zumindest vorher mehr so sopran und
jetzt mehr so vorher einfach tenor vor
genau etwa noch kritischer an dem sogar
höher
und jetzt einfach noch tiefer oder ja
jetzt sind auch die rote grüne oder und
danach danach nimmst dir wieder in zwei
grüne taktik halten
ich beantworte wir können doch beide auf
beide antwort also eben rider auf jede
frage antworten
ok
mittlerweile habt ihr drei youtube
channel bei dem seiter fand gute schüler
seite nicht oder ob also gute schüler
sind wir nicht aber es ist noch keine
flächen schüler also gute schüler für
mich ist ein guter spieler der nur
ansatzweise schreibt aber ich bin nicht
jemand der nur ein zum 2 2 traf sondern
eben doch dann einfach mal meistens zu
32 3 aber es ist auch nicht so tragisch
außerdem hatte dann ja aber besser
werden ja okay da ich aber die doch auch
aber dafür gibt es auch wieder
verbessere okay wir sind eure noten in
mathe mit israel ohne warte ich weiß ich
bin war ich ich will den note wesen das
in der 5 weil ich mache nicht gut bin so
das ist dafür habe ich im sport1 ja
trotzdem noch ein stück ist auch okay
ich gehe ich spiele spielt deutschland 2
wir sind keine mathematischen köpfe also
ich geb machte nachher übrigens ja ja ja
klar gut dann machen wir es ab sofort
auch okay so gibt es kann doch nicht mal
eine grüne gewählt wirklich wir sind
ganz erreichen
also ich bin ich so
so jung und doch so erfolgreich waren
sie wie ihr euch auf den bravo cover
komische frage also bald schon mal eine
bravo herr endlich auch noch nicht im
cover namen die man vor einem jahr oder
so wir hatten kleinen 1000 haben die
kleinen bericht über alles gemacht
ich weiß nicht also bei tätig war
überglücklich auf den bravo cover ich
weiß gar nicht kann sein ja glaub schon
wieder auf jeden fall cool ich weiß
nicht also bravo ist schon klasse eine
große zeitschrift und ich weiß nicht ich
weiß wann wenn wir wenn wir aus dem
bravo cover sind dann egal ich bin so
ich glaube ich den die rose haben wir
danach zwei grüne aber der roten
aufhören ja wieder unterliegt dann
nämlich dass sie gründete wo man auch
die wegen der pathologie westerwelle wir
youtube videos macht deswegen dass die
zuschauer wenn du besser bleibt gehen
mädchen auf und euch rein weil sie
hinterher
seit die richtige herzensbrecher ich
antwortete nein glaube ich ich dachte es
dazu naja also wenn irgendwelche fan
girls dem sie gekommen und ich liebe
euch man wird sich dann die ganzen
kommentare einige davon auf instagram
auf youtube und so weiter und naja was
soll man sagen also herzensbrecher also
mit einem fan irgendwie der beziehung zu
seinen diskussion weil sie doch weiß
nicht ob das so gehen kann
auch wenn jetzt tausende herz gebrochen
sind sollte aber das ist schon so eine
sache bei der man einfach sagen muss
dass man mit fans seine etwas anfangen
kann
so soll wer draußen microsoft uns auch
hängt davon ab vielleicht gibt's ja auch
fans die alten fans sind und trotzdem
einfach passen oder so trotzdem gut
sodass man kann auch im fernsehen von na
klar aber in der regel kann man mit fans
keine gescheite beziehungen für glaube
ich glaube ich okay es gibt auch meiner
ist es gibt noch eine rote und eine
grüne frage wo man zieht wurde und sich
spannung jetzt aufzubauen nehmen wir die
roten wie die brüder also die rote
bleibt noch offen film fürs ende nur
kurz
so musste eine dramatische musik kommen
wie bei rtl wie bei super zeit und unter
schwarzen liegt wohl seit edward ii der
zukunft nein sind wir nicht wir sind die
loches ots die eu erwartet ihre parodien
aber das bedeutet nicht dass irgendwie
genau identisch sind und wir machen
unser ding heute die macht ihr ding
trotzdem arbeiten wir unbedingt zusammen
und und so weiter und so fort aber wir
sind letztlich in die ateliers der
zukunft zumindest wir uns jetzt nicht so
ganz einfach die antwort jetzt fehlt
einer der zukunft werden dann dann
broich wir noch einen quoten töten
das heißt also eine so feine ja ich habe
die ehre die letzte frage zu beantworten
die letzte rote aber bist bist du bist
du bereit bist du bereit
meint ihr dass euch die pubertät
entwickelt den mix kriegskosten werden
alkohol besetzt hat uns ja auch nicht so
viele klicks gekostet wir machen ja
trotzdem relativ glücklich werden sind
für die abo verhältnisse also ich denke
nicht
also ich glaube nicht dass hoffenheim
also das werk das wäre böse wird jetzt
irgendwie welche uns duarte und die lte
abonnieren dagegen die pickel im gesicht
haben ich glaube es ist eigentlich
normal in dem alter obwohl sich das auf
jeden fall total lindert hat also von
einem jahr
vor einem jahr hatten wir wissen nicht
mehr weiter eingehen hat sich auch etwas
schon gelindert und dass wir auf jeden
fall krass wenn jetzt irgendwie an die
wand montiert würde sich die fragen aus
neuer größten fans ja da bin ich froh
dass das ganze jetzt nicht im fiasko
geendet ist das war ja gerade ganz
vielen dank dass ihr da wart dass er die
fragen bereitwillig beantwortet habt in
vielen dank dass wir interviewt werden
der vielen dank dass wir kommen dürften
und vielen dank vielen dank danke danke
danke danke
meint ihr okay dann ganz kurz danke
danke danke danke danke